What answer did you give, David?``
>> So,
my answer is that the best explanation
is a combination of Betatosis and Zetad.
By combining these two illnesses, we can
cover all of the data we saw over here.
We saw both illnesses elevate B,
which led to our High B, and
both reduced C, which led to our Low C.
Our patient had a normal level of E,
but the effects of Betatosis and
Zetad counteract their influence on E.
Then Zetad accounts for our Reduced F,
and Betatosis accounts for
our Reduced H.
My explanation, though, heavily
weights the principle of coverage.
I sacrifice parsimony by having
two different explanations for
the sake of coverage,
I now cover all the symptoms.
I could have also chose Thetadesis.
Thetadesis would have explained B,
C, and H.
It wouldn't explain F, but
it would be a simpler explanation than
the combination of Betatosis and Zetad.
In that case I would be sacrificing
coverage for parsimony.
I could also augment Thetadesis
with Kappacide and Mutension.
The three of them together would
cover all our symptoms, but
that would also be less parsimonious
than Betatosis and Zetad alone.
I may have chosen to do that though,
if those three diseases were much
more common than Betatosis and Zetad.
In which case, I would have more
confidence in them than just these two.
>> It's an excellent answer, David, but
how did you come up with this answer?
>> So what I did,
is I started with the data and
I looked at which of these hypotheses
currently matched the data best.
That is to say, which hypotheses
explained the most points and
had the fewest conflicts.
So for example, Betatosis explained the
High B, the Low C, and the Low H, but
it didn't explain the Low F, and
it also suggested there was Elevated E.
Initially, Thetadesis was the best
match, it explained three symptoms,
it just didn't explain the fourth.
Then, based on that, I went looking for
another illness that would
complete the explanation.
For Thetadesis, that ended up leading
me to Kappacide and Mutension, but
at that point,
I was using three different hypotheses.
So I decided to revisit one of the
closer matches from my original round.
I revisited Betatosis, which had two
mismatches, it predicted Elevated E and
didn't explain the Reduced F.
And I went looking for
another hypothesis that would
complete that explanation.
Zetad happened to have
exactly those two effects.
>> Note that one can use alternative
methods for the same problem.
For example, one could use
case-based reasoning, and for it,
we came across a problem very
similar to this one previously.
Suppose that the solution to that
particular problem was of a level
as a case.
In that particular case, B was high,
C was lower, F was low, and
the solution was Thetadesis.
In the current problem,
the additional symptom is that F is low.
So case would force you to
the conclusion of Thetadesis.
But it will create this particular
solution to also account for
the additional symptom of F being low.
We could do that by adding Kappacide and
Mutension to Thetadesis.
Case-based reasoning does,
will tend to forecast
the alternative set of hypothesis.
One more point to note here then,
note that different methods can
lead to different solutions.
Given different methods,
how might an error agent
decide which method to select?
We'll return to this particular problem
when we discuss meta reasoning.